[Music]
i understand that uh on this show james
van der beek we all remember uh start in
dawson's creek he plays himself on the
show he plays james van der beek yeah he
plays like a weird like narcissistic
monster version of himself in real life
he's very nice and zen i actually live
in his old house
how did that happen i was in new york
and the show got picked up thank you god
and he i sent a frantic email to
everyone in my address book saying i
need a place to live and he wrote back
is it kristin it's all good i have a
place and it's great it's got good vibes
and i know because i just moved out of
it
so
i moved in and i have a little dog and
my um my welcome gift was a bottle of
wolf urine pee
what wolf urine well yeah just urine is
pee yeah yeah same thing whatever um
so that the coyotes don't eat my dog
wait what yeah so i he gave me wolfie oh
so you love him in the hills somewhere
yeah yeah okay i'll get the exact
address later but you uh you so you live
up in the hills and and and there's a
lot of coyotes there's so many and they
prey on dogs and so this is what you're
supposed to do yeah you sprinkle it
around your house and you put it in it's
like brown and horrible you mean in the
yard not around the house
you're not supposed to walk around are
you walking around in your house
spreading wolf urine yeah just squirting
it everywhere you hang it in little
vials it's it's so disgusting it's like
really dark brown it scares the way the
coyotes maybe my friends what does it
smell like does it smell like urine yeah
dude it's disgusting
the poop experts jumping in
i love it she's amazing you've remained
completely silent now what's this
well
a topic i can weigh in on
i find this appalling that i mean i
didn't know first of all i mean uh
that's something that people really do
does it work so so wolves come down i
mean how does it keep the wolf away
coyotes coyotes oh well coyotes are
scared of walls yes oh okay now i'm
getting it i'm getting it so they like
if their territory is marked then the
coyotes won't come
i've seen them like in my back porch
i've seen three at a time they're so
scary
they cannot eat my little dog no and
they're just they're just hanging around
they know he's they're back there
they're like snapping their fingers like
this
we're gonna get you they're ringing the
doorbell yeah oh we're waiting for you
and then they approach but then it's
they just get close they're like
oh
urine and they're out the door exactly
i'm not kidding since i've had the wolf
urine i haven't even seen a single
coyote right i just do a commercial for
them do you think there's money i think
you just did
this stuff sounds fantastic where can i
get some
oh my god i'm so embarrassed no don't be
you trust me this is the right show for
this discussion
[Laughter]
this is what we i'm now interested in
the harvesting yeah
how do you get the wolf to pee into the
can
or jar
jar a macan jar or whatever it is maybe
it's synthetic i don't know i should i
should read them
maybe
james vanderbilt is a freak
and he just painted a jar and wrote wolf
on it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we now need a thorough investigation
we need to know you've got to come back
and you've got to bring james van der
beek and you've got to bring the wolf
the wolf who really has to go
we are going to solve all these matters